fear is a resistance to what it is that
you desire and in the absence of
resistance you become a magnet for what
you desire your successes will come when
you commit to joy when you commit to
happiness you could say all the right
things but if you don't think it if you
don't transform and clean up your
thinking then you're literally polluting
the planet
she's a motivational speaker life coach
and spirit junkie she's a New York Times
bestselling author of the universe has
your back her flagship course the spirit
junkie master class empowered people to
live their best self she's Gabrielle
Bernstein and here's my take on our top
ten rules of success rule number one is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below for cool to rent it to other
people can be inspired as well and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with you as well enjoy
don't wait go do it
act now I'm really accepting we need you
we need you we need you you are the 1%
you're the percent that says I'm going
to wake up you are the light workers you
are the ones that have accepted this
call in this lifetime at this time you
have decided to wake up and chosen to
say yes I'm here to be a greater service
and just to feed myself right I'm here
to feed the world I'm here to give love
I'm here to be an expression of that
truth don't hold that back
don't play small we can't we need you
and so really if you are anyone in this
room who has been sitting on that book
idea waiting a little bit longer before
you start that teacher training or doing
ten more teacher trainings before you
actually teach if that's you guys start
and the pressure will be off I can't
begin to tell you I could cry to saying
that the mo the day I taught you go
Eradicator I was two weeks into my
teacher training and I said f it let's
go and I just went and I felt so much
pressure off I felt so much lift because
I just knew I felt this technology must
be shared I can't hold it I can't keep
it for myself I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this I gotta
give this and sharing it the pressure
there just lifted it was like oh thank
you thank you thank you and I wasn't the
perfect teacher and I look back and I
was teaching he's already Kate or wrong
everyone's arms were like this everyone
was breathing backwards it was a mess
but I did it and I started and in those
moments when we just get to go just go
the pressure is off and then we clear
the past and we are guided to the next
right action and that is the most
magnificent thing that could you right
now Wow what's the first step to
overcoming the fear or transforming this
fear hmm to witness it to be to be the
non-judgmental witness of it to look at
it and say something's got to give
right so so
if you're unwilling to look at your fear
head-on and honor it and and witnessed I
always say if you don't show up for
what's up it will keep showing up so
looking and saying you know I witness my
resistance and you see that fear as
resistance it's right it's fear as a
resistance to what it is that you desire
and in the absence of resistance you
become a magnet for what you desire when
you let go of that fear and you
transcend that fear that's when you
start to become a super attractor that's
when you start to let what is truly of
essence for you into your life what is
truly of service for you into your life
what is true happiness into your life
and so looking at the fear witnessing it
calling it by its name and even if you
don't have the tools yet what happens is
when you look at the fear and you're
like oh I see this fear I see this
resistance I see how it's blocking my
life and I choose to see it differently
that's when you're listening to an audio
like this that's in a book like yours
will fall off the shelf the catalyst
yeah you know exactly you open up your
consciousness pretty much you crack open
your consciousness to find solutions
rather than find problems and so when
you're not looking at the theory you're
just living in the fear and you're
believing in the problem but when you
witness the fear are you willing to see
it differently you start living in the
solution as I commit to happiness fully
exactly what I need is coming towards me
because I become a magnet I become an
energy field that is so magnetizing that
is so excited that's so inspired that
other people want to support and work
with that energy and so when we dwell in
the energy of joy and happiness we
become a magnet for that which we desire
so my hope for you all is to start to
think about the things that you want to
succeed in whether it's succeeding in
romantic relationships or succeeding in
your career or succeeding in your health
goals and make a commitment today to
bring more joy to that area of your life
rather than seeing it as a struggle
rather than pushing forward with all
this angst and negativity and neediness
and control just bring joy to it your
successes will come when you commit to
joy when you commit to happiness
so find more joy in that physical
exercise I've been going to SoulCycle I
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and
helping me raise my but because that was
one of my goals and success and and then
we have these moments where we want to
really bring joy into our career well if
you're having a hard time in the office
just find ways to have more fun and as
we start to elevate that presence of joy
we will begin to magnetize the successes
in our life and so take this very
seriously bring this practice into your
day-to-day experiences and make joy and
happiness your number one priority
and recognize how your successes will be
brought to you in a form far greater
than you could ever imagine when your
primary focus is happiness once you make
that willingness to change the book
falls off the shelf or the teacher shows
up in a form that you could have never
imagined or you hear something on the
radio or you meet a cab driver or some
enlightened conversation comes into your
realm that all of a sudden is that shift
that you needed to make that change and
create that catalyst that becomes your
greatest accomplishment your greatest
shift and so that's all we need at first
is that slight willingness that
willingness that I had that desire to
change that moment to shift with all I
needed to become the woman I am today to
live that life beyond my wildest dreams
and so when I became ready I opened up
and I said okay I'm ready for change but
what's beautiful and was the main
purpose of what I teach is that once you
make that decision to change you do not
have to do it by yourself you cannot be
expected to make these changes on your
own all you need is that slight
willingness presenting somebody else
you're really just unconsciously
resenting yourself so witnessing very
quickly who do I need to forgive is it
me is it somebody else
and very quickly turning it back on to
you and choosing the pathway of
forgiveness forgiving yourself for
having a judgmental thought forgiving
yourself for being in attack forgiving
yourself for having a feeling that is
untimed forgiving yourself for being
judgmental towards yourself or tapping
towards itself whatever is up for you in
the moment just practice the f-word and
if you can't get to the feeling of
forgiving yourself say
you are willing to forgive yourself just
saying in that moment I am willing to
forgive myself for X Y Z I'm willing to
forgive myself for being in this bad
mood I'm willing to forgive myself for
what I just said I'm willing to forgive
myself for what I'm holding on to and
just opening yourself up to the practice
of self forgiveness will change your
mood and your energy in a minute or less
I swear by this this is probably the key
to my freedom my happiness my successes
is my willingness to forgive myself so
take that in and really own that for you
and practice the f-word all the time so
the next time you notice yourself in a
bad mood it might just be right in this
moment right now to say I'm willing to
forgive myself and see what unfolds see
how your energy changes see how your
feelings begin to shift and see that bad
mood just dissipate instantly there are
no idle thoughts so if you want to live
a mindful life you have to recognize the
magnitude of your thinking if you're
sitting here and you're you know you're
judging your your loved ones you're
judging a friend you're weakening your
own energy and you're weakening there's
every being around you in some ways
picking up the frequency of your
thoughts some people are looking
perplexed like what the hell is she
talking about right now I can hear your
thoughts I got I know exactly what
you're thinking it's not that I can hear
it that I can feel it think about it you
know you could be in those relationships
for like you're your boss and you know
you do everything perfectly but in your
head you like I hate you I hate you I
hate you I hate you and they just they
don't want to promote you they don't
want to support you there's constant
tension within the relationship you
could say all the right things but if
you don't think it if you don't
transform and clean up your thinking
then you're literally polluting the
planet so first and foremost what I
think about what we're thinking and so
how do we change those thoughts because
you have you think okay that sounds
great but like I'm down Negative Nancy
lein and I don't know how to change
direction how do I make a u-turn alright
so some simple tools
first and foremost witness it yesterday
I was saying this look look at you're
crazy and call it by its name it's fear
when you see those crazy thoughts show
up in your life when you hear those
thoughts of I'm not good enough I'm
better than that person is terrible
I have two choices I can continue down
the road I can continue down that dark
path or I can actually pivot I can
redirect I can choose again so let's
just play it out you're walking around
wanderlust and somebody cuts you in line
to the pizza truck and you know I'd be
pissed somebody caught me a lot of that
pieces drop and and you want to go like
five a copy a lie to put it in that
space notice your angst witness your
story and instead of thinking I'm going
to fight back think that is a call for
love anyone who has the audacity to cut
me in the pizza line but seriously like
anyone that's rude because I I cut in
the piece of line sometimes like I'm a
cutter III Electric I lives with it oh
really what is it it's my own insecurity
be like I got to show people that I can
get ahead of the line or whatever it is
right seeing anything like that is their
call for love that's their
unconsciousness that's their that's
their that's a lack of mindfulness
really really feel what it would feel
like to be in the action of what it is
that you're dreaming of and what does
that feel like to be the on the career
path that is your dream or what does it
feel like to be doing the work in the
world that you've been so long and to
bring forth or what does it feel like to
be spreading an empowering message in a
unique and innovative way and in the
process of gathering those feelings we
do it through meditation sit in your
meditation for two to three minutes a
day and just allow yourself to cultivate
the feeling of what it is that you
desire I have had many experiences
throughout my life where I've just
allowed myself to be in the feeling of
service or in the feeling of excitement
of seeing myself on a stage or in the
feeling of seeing myself sitting next to
Oprah doing an interview and all of
those emotional feelings that came forth
in my meditations became the
manifestations of my life to take very
seriously the thoughts and the feelings
when we start to shift our perception
when we start to see things with a
better person
when we start to see our experiences as
obstacles turning into opportunities or
a resentment as a divine assignment to
forgive more or a moment of lack as an
opportunity to focus on what we're
grateful for rather than focus on what
we don't have we start to make these
shifts within our life what begins to
happen is that we begin to have more
faith in that way of being and so the
neat thing that occurs and this has been
my experience that has six years of
practicing the life of a spirit junkie
is that now my choices my
moment-to-moment choices are choosing
more of a positive perspective when
there's traffic my first thought is okay
I welcome the traffic to go I try to
start to think about the ways or if I'm
supposed to be late maybe I'm meant to
be there late maybe there's something
greater coming or something doesn't
happen the exact way that I believe it
should happen I know and my first
thought is there's something way greater
coming so this is just two types of
types of miracles that occur in the ways
that your mind begins to shift when you
start to practice these principles in
your every corner of your life I think
it's really valuable for us to recognize
that we when we're on a spiritual path
that's our path but is not for everybody
and not everyone wants to know every
detail of our path we have to trust that
our shift in perception are energetic
changes are the raising of our own
energy will help raise the energy of
other people around us and hopefully
we'll start to see how we are no longer
an energetic match for the people that
don't think and feel the way that we
feel and so slowly we'll begin to see
those folks begin to melt away we'll see
them disappear we'll see them fall off
in our lives and we'll see some of our
relationships begin to change and
sometimes it's a little bit alarming for
people but it's actually a good sign
it's a sign that you are not stuck in
that pattern anymore it's a sign that
your desire to change has been lifted
and that you now are vibrating in a new
frequency and those relationships will
melt away
if those relationships are still coming
up for you while you're in this path of
transformation
what I often say is rather than pointing
the finger at those people saying oh
you're ruining my life you're making
things difficult my hope and my
intention for you would be that you
begin to look at those folks and say
what is it about me that is still
triggered by their behavior what is it
in me that may be attracting this type
of person into my life
what is it within me that is still
calling in this kind of experience and
so get honest with yourself what is it
within me that's calling this in how am
i participating in this and how is this
experience coming from a dark corner
within my psyche and recognizing that
the outside world is always reflecting
our internal condition and recognizing
the mirror that people are always
mirroring back to us what we are feeling
so if she has people coming up into her
life negative friends people that are
jealous
she says negative people randomly
popping back in and she wants to keep
them in a distance so the real work is
to just open and rev up your practice
pray for them extend light to them and
sometimes politely excuse yourself from
the experience sometimes we have to
remove ourselves from those experiences
and then most importantly ask yourself
what is it within me that may be
attracting some of this behavior get
honest with yourself okay
no matter what's up choose to show up
with love to just show up with grace now
something really tough is up maybe just
choose to show up with self compassion
if you're going through something I'm
not going to sit here and recommend if
you're going through a traumatic period
in your life I'm not going to recommend
that you wake up and you're like it's
rainbows and butterflies and Gabby
Bernstein spirit junkie app no that's
not what I'm going to match that's not
what I'm going to recommend what I'm
going to recommend is you wake up and
you say I'm going to choose to see
myself with love today I'm going to
choose to be compassionate and kind to
myself today I'm going to go slow today
but that's still a very very mindful
morning okay so more in the morning is
probably the most crucial time to be
conscious of your mindfulness and show
up with grace and show up with love and
bring it bring it bring it bring it in
the morning
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kim asked me to
also if you want to nominate someone for
the next top ten video please check the
description for a link to video where
you can vote for people and put in your
suggestions as well I'd love to know
what did you take from this video what
was the most important lesson that you
learned that blew your mind that you're
going to immediately apply to your life
or your business somehow please leave it
down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Steph
Reverend Steph thank you so much for
breaking up a copy of my book your one
word and post another great picture to
Instagram I really appreciate the
support and I'm glad you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll season
it's very easy to show up to work
everyday and say I hate this I can't
stand my boss I hate sitting next to the
earth in my cubicle sucks there's a
million ways we can get completely
whacked out with the stories of why we
don't like our job so just have fun and
lean towards the things that that
elevate you and the more is just focus
on the things that are fun for you and
the more you focus on the good that is
around you the more fun you become more
cool you become when you're in that
place of your cool people want to do
more with you you'll get those
assignments that are going to be far
more exciting the people that may be
difficult in your career relationships
will start to actually change they'll
see you differently they'll act
differently around you when you're
having a good time the people around you
have a good time and that will help you
get ahead very quickly smoothly and with
joy the next phase here is also to
become grateful for what it is that you
do have so if you're starving to try to
create change in your life you want to
make sure that you're really focusing on
what it is that you do have in your life
so that you feel an energy of gratitude
and an energy of gratitude can really
open you up to this incredible capacity
to feel more energized to feel more
happy in any given moment where you feel
like oh I don't have what I need or I'm
not supported or things aren't working
out the simple step here is to just say
I am grateful for what I do have and let
me look at me say I'm grateful for what
I do have we create more of what we want
and the energy of gratitude opens our
heart and it expands our energy and it
makes us a much more wonderful loving
person to be around
and with that loving energy we begin to
attract more into our life and so we
want to really make sure that that
energy of gratitude is a very pinnacle
part of this rope this miracle worker
process which is that we stay committed
and open to what it is that we are here
to receive and we stay committed and
grateful for what it is that we have and
so you can begin today just by making a
gratitude list and focus on it and
there's so many moments when I think oh
my god I can't believe I have to do that
so I can't the best to get to that and
and then I just think about what I'm
grateful for and it just spins me
immediately out of the crazy chaos and
back into a centered place of love and
so I think that this is a really
valuable tool for you to begin to use
regularly and it's an active tool
throughout the book may cause miracles
when you fully accept that you are here
to be great when you fully accept that
you are here to be happy when you fully
accept that you are here to receive when
you fully accept that you can have the
peace and the serenity and the joy and
the wisdom and the purpose and the
intention that you intend to bring to
the world and that it is all available
to you that's when life gets very groovy
and so my hope and my intention for
today is to wake you up to that presence
I more importantly give you a really
great New York City kick in the ass that
says not only I'm awake to it not only
do I believe in it but I am committed to
it
I am unapologetic about my capacity to
be great
I'm unapologetic about my capacity to
heal I'm unapologetic about my capacity
to see beyond my physical sight I'm
unapologetic about my capacity to shine
as bright as I can shine because I trust
and I know that when I shine bright
I give others permission to do the same
and in my glow they wake up to and that
is why we're here
[Music]